Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is my Constantine
Episode 2 video.
It was almost like a second first episode.
We got to meet Zed, she’s the new female
lead character.
So I’ll explain her backstory in the comics.
They changed the show just a little after
the pilot was shot, so I’ll explain what
they kept, namely the Map which is going to
be what they use to find new dark arts to
dabble in all over the united states.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up, starting with Top 5 Moments
Number 5 - Constantine Road Trip
They’ll be traveling all over the place
using that map.
This week it was a middle of nowhere mining
town in Pennsylvania.
I was surprised they didn’t pick a bigger
location for their second episode but the
explanation for why it had to be a small town
ties back into the bigger Dark Constantine/Demon
plot teased in episode 1.
Evil is spreading everywhere, including dead
mining towns.
The miner did tunnel into a supernatural area.
But that’s not what made all the Coblinau
go crazy.
It didn’t help either.
The spreading darkness that we’ll just see
in all of the episodes threw gasoline on the
flames.
It gave the gypsy woman’s power extra juice
and it forced more of the coblinau to manifest.
I don’t expect them to explain this spreading
evil right away, we probably won’t learn
what it’s all about until we learn what
the inner circle of demons are planning.
Number 4 - The Coblinau Spirits
There aren’t a lot of details about these
spirits in the comics but in classic mythology
they’re a lot like Cave Goblins.
Here they’re the trapped spirits of dead
miners.
Remember, Constantine explained that the spirits
you can see on earth are trapped, they’re
not supposed to be here.
That’s why Heaven was so freaked out in
the first episode they sent Manny to enlist
Constantine’s help.
The mining operation just shook them up a
bit, they gypsy was what turned them into
killers.
They were made out of mud, which is why constantine
almost drowned in mud inside that car.
They reminded me visually of Melisandre’s
shadow baby from Game of Thrones.
It’s getting a lot easier for television
to do visual effects like this, so expect
some more cool looking creature effects this
season.
They won’t just be dealing with Demons,
it will be all manner of spirits and supernatural
creatures.
I know everyone is bummed this is never going
to cross over with Supermantural on the CW,
because Team Winchester exists in pretty much
the same universe.
Not literally, but the two shows look very
similar.
Number 3 - Constantine Dabbles In The Dark
Arts
I don’t think him casting the spell on the
jar of water was dark magic, but I was waiting
for him to use some of his powers in a visual
way.
He does have powers but most of the time he
works through other agents like Zed who have
much more specific abilities.
Constantine’s supernatural ability in the
comics
allows him to create his own luck.
He uses it to talk his way out of situations.
He’s claimed to have pulled a fast one on
both Lucifer and God.
So when Zed asked him what he was going to
use for protection and he said my wits.
That was what he was talking about.
When he’s on his game he can talk his way
out of anything.
He’s a pretty epic mess of a human being
though, so his wits don’t save him from
getting his ass handed to him on a regular
basis.
I also love that the priest just waves off
his incantation to try and stop him.
It’s just the show telling us that constantine
isn’t invincible.
People call bullshit on him all the time.
Now that we have Zed, there will be a lot
more of that.
Just much more playful.
Number 2 - You Need Faith To Raise Evil
Constantine was able to raise the dead husband’s
spirit, so he must have a little bit of faith
in him.
He does despise both Heaven and Hell, but
his spells wouldn’t have any power if he
didn’t have faith.
They also had a big call out to that in the
first episode.
When the shadow constantine said his spells
lack the power of conviction.
I expect them to pay off that idea at least
a few more times.
His faith will be tested, he’ll fail and
then have some big epic success against one
of the big villains.
All part of the heroe’s Journey.
Him raising the evil spirit was also a nice
callback to his story about Astrid being drug
to hell by a demon he raised.
That’s one of the bigger arcs.
I don’t know if they’ll take the series
that far in season 1.
If they’ll let Constantine go to hell to
rescue her.
That’s something we haven’t seen yet.
Constantine actually in Hell.
I feel like that’s coming.
and my Number 1 moment - Meet Zed Martin
Okay, so if you haven’t read the comcis,
Zed is from Hellblazer.
She appeared for the first time in Hellblazer
number 4.
So she’s old school.
Over the years she and Constantine have had
an on again off again sexual relationship.
She’s the female lead so she’d have to
have sexual chemistry with her co-star.
But they pushed it pretty far in the episode
and that’s why.
They were a huge thing in the comics.
One of her big story arcs was Ressurection
Crusade.
She was targeted by a cult led by her father
to become the vessel for the next messaih.
But she had sex with constantine the night
before the ritual and they required a virgin.
It gets ugly and she dies while it’s all
going down.
I don’t think the show will kill off Angelica
Celaya anytime soon.
So just expect them to avoid that storyline
on the show.
All in total she was around in the comics
for a little over 30 issues.
She was a really big deal so it’s awesome
that they’re doing her on the show.
Let me know, What was your favorite moment
and what do you think of Zed so far?
While you think about that, here are a few
easter eggs I spotted.
First are Constantine’s Tattoos.
We only see them on him in the episode, but
the movie made them a big thing.
They’re a proprietary blend of custom runes.
and We got a much better look at Zed’s charcoal
drawings.
They’re all covers of Hellblazer comics.
Let me know if you spotted any other big references,
just write them in the comments.
Overall I gave the episode a B, I thought
it was stronger than the Pilot.
But Pilot’s change so much, usually second
episodes get better.
Producers and writers are able to fix things
they don’t think worked, recast actors if
they need to.
It’s going to be a few more episodes before
we get into the rhythm of the characters.
And even though I love Lucy Griffiths I feel
like the Zed character is a much better foil
for Constantine.
I’m going to give them a few episodes together
before I pass judgement but so far I like
their energy.
They have a very honeymoon suite kind of energy.
Next week I think the other main characters
are back, so we should get to see the full
team in action.
The real purpose of this episode was to intro
the Zed character.
I loved the way they played that ending too.
They’re presenting her as equal parts bad
and good for Constantine.
They have this weird symbiotic relationship
where they’re really awesome and really
bad for each other at the same time.
Next week, Papa Midnite from the comics is
joining the show.
So be sure to subscribe to get my video.
I’ll post it after the episode airs.
And heads up.
The Doctor Who finale is happening over the
next two weeks.
It’s a two parter.
So be sure to check that out.
It’s going to be crazy.
Right now click here for my Constantine Episode
1 video and click here for my Constantine
History Video from the Comics.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you this weekend!